for the third time the US Senate failed
to pass a bill to fight the Zika virus
on their first day back from summer
recess lawmakers were eight votes short
of the total needed for the 1.1 billion
dollar bill Democratics Democrats rather
overwhelmingly voted against it partly
because a bill included language to
defund some plan parenthood programs the
CDC said last week that its funding to
fight the virus has nearly run out
Senate leaders have promised to get a
bill approved by the end of this month
Miami Beach will begin using a
controversial chemical tomorrow to fight
Zika seven new locally transmitted cases
of the virus reported yesterday in
miami-dade County six of those were in
Miami Beach that brings the number of
non travel related infections in Florida
256 David beg no is in miami beach with
concerns over the new effort to
eliminate the virus david good morning
charlie good morning that aerial
spraying begins at around five a.m.
tomorrow morning it's an aggressive new
approach at targeting the mosquitoes
that carry the Zika virus the chemical
that is going to be used as an
insecticide now it is being sprayed over
the city in a mist and every expert
we've talked to said it's such a fine
miss such a small amount that it's
harmless to humans but I got to tell you
trying to convince people here on Miami
Beach that it's actually harmless is
proving difficult just yesterday Miami
Beach began widespread ground spraying
using a natural bacterium called bti it
slowly kills mosquito larvae but with
mosquito counts on the rise that fight
will now be taken to the air as it was
in the Miami neighborhood of Winwood
last month planes carrying a powerful
neurotoxin called nallett will be used
to target adult mosquitoes over a one
and a half square mile area of miami
beach now it is banned by the european
union but the EPA's website says it has
been used in this country since nineteen
fifty-nine without posing unreasonable
risks when applied according to the
label at high doses however it can
overstimulate the nervous system causing
nausea dizziness or confusion EPA says
it's safe yes do you believe that as the
mayor well I believe that the EPA is
telling us the truth I believe the CDC
on there
website explains specifically and
exactly what aerial spraying is about
and I do believe what the CDC says yes
the CDC had previously said aerial
spraying over Miami Beach wouldn't work
due to the city's high-rise buildings
and wind currents the use of knowledge
is also causing an uproar on social
media residents are petitioning local
and state leaders to reverse the
decision one of them is Alberto gross
he's lived on Miami Beach for seven
years the solution could be just as bad
as the problem you know why are they
doing this why aren't they listening to
the residents of miami beach the
spraying tomorrow morning is going to be
done at 5am because they want to do it
before kids go to school just in an
abundance of caution there was a city
commissioner yesterday who told CBS News
he was ready to file a lawsuit to stop
the county from spraying but nor this
morning he's saying he doesn't think he
can assemble the votes with fellow
commissioners to get it done so it looks
like the spring will happen it's an
interesting debate David thank you so
much